alors on va passer au troisième débat de
la soirée les anges existe foule mais
d'abord pour affaire qui arditi une
hyper view bah oui bah ouais c'est vrai
que ça vous tombe dessus un moment là
avec fish et on va faire une hyper view
que ça va donner vous donner en plus
l'occasion de répondre à un certain
nombre de papiers que j'ai vu sur vous
dernièrement et qui étaient pas tous
très sympathiques en tous les cas
donc on va vous pouvez poser des
questions aussi à pierre arditi pts 7
passes sont les mêmes que moi mais sur
des sujets plus privé signification plus
intéressante qu'elle est plus
intéressante que moi ça sera difficile
alors il y avait un article dans libé
c'était lundi dernier la vie aux qui
disait pierre arditi talent caché caché
c'est acheter il parlait de vous en
disant vous faites partie des acteurs
qui comptent les gros le gros des
cachets de la fiction à la télé oui et
il parlait de stars vieillissantes
oui bon parce que comme on a presque le
même âge je trouve ça ignoble je tiens à
le dire
d'abord il faudrait expliquer à la
personne qui a écrit ça non je ne sais
pas le nom puisque c'est maintenant
c'est juste des initiales ami et parent
initial
ça c'est exagéré oui vous douala parce
que c'est très exactement ce que veulent
les 10 c à vous d'avoir faudra déjà
cessé d'employer ce mot à tord et à
travers parce qu'il signifie plus rien
une star c'est quelque chose de très
particulier il y en a extrêmement peu je
n'en fais pas partie
alors c'est pas du tout de la fausse
modestie chez moi je ne suis absolument
pas une star ensuite bon je ne vois pas
trop l'intérêt de
ne me regardez de cette manière là
d'abord bien évidemment je ne pompe pas
à moi tout seul l'ensemble de l'argent
de la fiction je vois que sur certains
certaines chaînes ils en font tellement
peu qu'après tout on peut penser que
jean pompe une bonne sortie de pas si
c'est le nom voilà non mais je veux dire
par là que je n'ai rien à dire sur le
fait qu'on puisse critiquer en
l'occurrence une série de télévision qui
s'appellerait un font six que j'ai
tourné composite fossey vanek du prr
certain nombre d'autres je comprends
très bien qu'on n'aime pas ça on a tout
à fait le droit de dire ça me choque
absolument pas je n'ai aucun rien à dire
là dessus je ne vois pas l'intérêt de me
plus de me taper la gueule de cette
manière-là d'abord parce que tout ça est
évidemment totalement faux je ne
fonctionne pas plus qu'un certain nombre
d'autres gens qui travaillent dans la
finance et même chaîne qu'ensuite mon
dieu je suis j'ai toujours dit je crois
que je monte je suis un acteur
pluridisciplinaire ça que je fais du
théâtre du cinéma de la télévision
quelquefois même jeudi les textes que je
mon honneur à moi c'est de passer d'un
aréna feydeau ou de beckett à guitry que
je considère que mon métier c'est ça que
j'ai été baigné dans ce bain là puisque
nous avons près le même âge et que nous
avons été biberonné à robert ishmael
beah brauner des rires j'ai été
biberonné à jouvet j'ai été biberonné à
brasseur je ne me compare pas à eux mais
autant que je m'en souvienne ces gens là
faisait aussi un peu ça c'est à dire que
brasseur disait lui-même
je vais m'amuser dans la journée je vais
faire mon métier le sérère très bon donc
je vois pas en quoi cette chose sera une
tare ensuite que ce soit vieillissant
naturellement je suis vieillissant je
trouve que finalement je vis plutôt pas
trop mal que tu es plutôt mieux 56,5
est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
pierre arditi vide franchement oui je
trouve qu'un homme un homme est plus
beau quand nous disons merci beaucoup
plus beaucoup continuer parce qu'il
devient plus mature et voilà c'est vrai
c'est passé près tout simplement pour
dire tout ça pour dire eh bien cette
grotte
tout ça tout ça pour dire que ça m'a
profondément déplu non pas qu'on n'aime
pas cette série ça je manque enfin tape
complètement mais que cette manière de
me regarder
je la trouve infâme et finalement comme
dirait l'autre il ya des lettres qui
vaut mieux recevoir plutôt que de les
avoir écrites la déshonore leurs auteurs
16 ans minutes ça vous en erdre et - oui
je relève vraiment j'ai vu bien sûr vous
avez raison ça me ça me blesse parce
qu'une certaine manière c'est un journal
que j'aime bien et c'est un journal que
je lui pratiquement tous les jours et ma
lecture de libération s'arrête aux pages
politiques organique là je ne lis plus
les pages culturelles de libération qui
sont j'ai le regret de le dire des pages
totalement incomplète pour le moins qui
encensent une toute petite partie de ce
qui se passe culturellement dans notre
pays et en conséquence de quoi je trouve
que les pages de cultura de libération
ne font pas leur boulot non pas parce
qu'elle n'attaque mois encore une fois
ça me blesse puisque j'aime bien ce
journal je veux dire que cette manière
de regarder fait un peu penser à une
presse d'occupation qui tout d'un coup
deviendrait racisme là je n'ai pas envie
qu'on deviendra site avec moi je crois
n'avoir rien fait dans ma vie qui mérite
ce traitement la très bien non mais ce
qu'on pourrait dire est ce que le fait
les cinquante trois ans donc est ce que
le ca 54 est-ce que je suis jeune que
vous alors est ce que la question avant
de passer à rêver peut-être vous préparé
une série pour france 2 qui s'appelle
les 80 une marque qui est donc qui parle
des gens de gauche qui ont perdu leur
âme après 80 parle de tout de tout un
groupe de gens qui traversent cette
période au moment où la gauche arrive au
pouvoir qu'ils sont pas forcément de
gauche
je n'ai pas ce sentiment a perdu votre
âme vous non je n'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir perdu mon âme et je n'ai pas
l'impression que tous les gens de gauche
est forcément perdu leur âme même si à
certains moments ils se sont un peu
perdus
très bien alors on en arrive à rêver
peut-être donc et la pièce qu de jean
claude grumberg que vous jouez au
théâtre du rond point des champs elysées
avec michel aumont marcel maréchal et
chantal neuwirth mise en scène de jean
michel ribes or ce que je veux dire
parce que là je suis pas critique de
cinéma eric est donc là ok league le
théâtre et les pieds non plus vrai c'est
vrai qu'on est allé voir cette pièce est
que les lieux main dans la main dans la
main puisque maintenant comme vous le
savez un ensemble en accédant que non
mais sérieusement on sait je dire c'est
une pièce grave
mais le texte est tellement drôlement
écrit avec certaines fois d'ailleurs
grunberg le deed un côté un peu almanach
vermot un essai tellement mis en scène
une façon joyeuse par ribes que
finalement un thème aussi grave
quelqu'un qui ne venger son père dans le
père a disparu pendant la guerre qui
veulent venger repas j'en parle mal
parce que dit nous c'est un rêve en fait
ce qui est formidable c'est que c'est
que c'est comme un vrai c'est comme un
rêve comme un rêve
oui mais c'est au fond la pièce elles
disent que ce que grumberg a assez
souvent dit il est obsédé par l'image de
ce père déporté qui ne connaît pas et au
fond à l'intérieur de ce dans l'atelier
le levain thématique est très classique
et très terrienne on attend quelqu'un
doit revenir ici on voit apparaître une
sorte de spectre qui est un spectre qui
est à la fois le spectre d'avnet mais
qui est aussi le spectre de ce père
perdu simplement les dans le domaine du
rêve et on est dans le domaine de la
nuit n'est là le combat de la nuit l'a
emporté sur le combat du jour et la nuit
tout est possible tout est permis mais
plus rien ne sera puni
oui et c'est ça en fait la thématique de
la pièce ça ni au milieu d'un bain d'un
magma qui est celui d'un rêve globale
qui comme dans tous les rêves semblent
n'avoir ni queue ni tête et quand même
petit à petit ça prend une cohérence des
enfants on ira par par emmené par en et
sweet home est en réalité d'ailleurs cet
enfant homme vers sa douleur initial qui
est celle de la perte de ce pays un
enfant qui n'a selon lui pas chantal
neuwirth au début c'est ça c'est son
épouse après c'est sa mère dans sa femme
c'est ça c'est très on dirait je sais
pas si c'est une bonne façon d'envoyer
les gens voient la pièce mais ça fait
penser à un bon trip d'acide quoi c'est
bien bien briller ou les sciences et
j'ai tous les baby boomer comprendront
ce que je veux dire très bien merci
pierre